joe biden and vladimir putin share
something in common they're both running
into some problems at home
and both men are using similar tactics
to hide the truth
we expect that from the russian
president
not our president
let's start in russia
putin can't keep a lid on reality during
a war this is 2022 the dam's cracking
check out this news editor who crashed a
live broadcast to let the russian people
know what's been going on more on this
in a moment
but putin's run into resistance
everywhere so he's cranking up the
propaganda the levels we haven't seen
since 2014.
when he invaded crimea
putin kinis
started popping up all over the beaches
russian women were seen sporting putin
bikinis to push patriotism and show
support for russia's interests
and now putin's looking for new sources
of disinformation
russia is paying
young russian tick-tock stars to push
his talking points
the videos follow the exact same script
like a kremlin press release actually
watched
but where did putin get this idea from
well maybe he was watching the biden
white house
for the last year the biden
administration has been using idiotic
tick tock videos to push for instance
vaccinations on kids
bing bong are you vaccinated yes sir hey
yup
do we get it
we got it hi my name is cooper and this
is a day in my life as a white house
intern we've come a long way in our
fight against this virus we've
vaccinated 160 million americans are you
getting this all down don't worry queen
all right here
things have gotten
pretty bad politically for joe biden
since then if you can imagine
so he asked actual teenagers for help
that's right he invited 30 tick tock
stars to a zoom call
for a briefing on the war in ukraine
well the real goal was to push partisan
government propaganda
and the kids actually did it
we are seeing the united states
sanctions on russia work russia's
economy is in free fall the ruble is at
its lowest point a no-fly zone is more
equivalent to boots on the ground
military action this type of action
would escalate the war further and cause
far more damage russia is one of the top
three producers of oil putin starting
this horrific fight between ukraine and
russia nobody wants to work with him and
do an international trade so with people
being scared of war and limited
resources prices are bound to go up as
well
instead of inviting american energy ceos
to a white house meeting you know to
figure out what the hell's going on with
gas prices
joe's inviting teenagers over for a
little propaganda party
see kids are very easy to manipulate and
biden knows that so instead of fixing
problems
biden just gets puppets to point fingers
tick tock is full of kids making stupid
videos swallowing tide pods putting a
penny an electric socket and just
lighting stuff on fire or
just dancing
[Music]
the president's using a dance app for
disinformation
and tic tocs owned by the chinese
chinese communist government controls a
large stake of the company
even biden's propaganda is made in china
but maybe the reason biden's turning to
teenagers to push his little propaganda
is because the mainstream media won't do
it for him that much anymore
remember nancy pelosi told the press
they needed to do a better job of
selling the democrats agenda
at the end of last year well
clearly they didn't listen
hosts
aren't falling in line like they used to
anymore watch if you look at the numbers
inflation
really started to rise almost exactly
when when biden came in the white house
if putin thought trump was really that
supportive of him
why didn't he invade when trump was in
office
it's at least worth asking that question
if you're not locked into one
intransigent thought apparently saudi
arabia won't even pick up the phone for
the president of the united states you
know what you can say what you want but
this
would have never happened to donald
trump
so when joe doesn't have the media to
convince people nothing's his fault he
basically uses child
actors so what types of topics were
coming up on this tick tock zoom call
besides ukraine well of course the
russia hoax
the best antidote to disinformation is
the truth if you look back um at 2014
and frankly even 2016 when russia
invaded ukraine and then in 2016 when
they you know of course hacked our
election here um
it we did not do that right we did not
decide we did not declassify information
but biden couldn't even convince all the
young kids to sell his lies
one of the young guys who was on the
call with the white house
told the washington post quote
the overall tone of the briefing was too
soft
and that officials dodged hard questions
felt like a press briefing for
kindergarteners
and speaking of kindergartners this
white house has a history of using them
my mom was a scientist and i just love
the idea of exploring the unknown
and then there's other things that we
just haven't figured out or discovered
yet wait till you guys see the moon i'm
telling you i just i don't know what it
is about those craters on the boat
those were child actors
from canada
again
not even biden's propaganda is made in
america
even saturday night live dunked on
biden's latest stunt
thank you all so much for coming and
answering your nation's call in a time
of need oh yeah sure hey no problem i'm
12. i also want to thank my press
secretary jinsaki for having the mission
to set this up i suggested it as a joke
and then it actually happened
people are saying this is a first war
fought on tick tock which is tough for
me because i'm the landline of
presidents
but the sad reality is this isn't funny
it's insulting
also the similarities between american
left-wing ideology and russian statism
is pretty striking
we showed you this video before
russia arresting people in the media for
speaking out against the kremlin now
vlad created a law to ban people from
spreading what he calls fake news
does that sound familiar
democrats in the media have spent the
last two years advocating for that
they've been consistently trying to
silence conservatives and call anything
they don't like misinformation
the liberal media has been calling for a
silencing of fox
since russia invaded ukraine
because apparently if you ask questions
and raise issues outside the mainstream
it must mean that you're the enemy of
the state
they're now even calling for the justice
department to go after tucker
and tulsi gabbard
and shut them up
what tucker carlson parrots evernight on
fox news what tulsi gabbard is spreading
is actually helping putin get away with
criminal acts against innocent ukrainian
civilians i think doj in the same way
that it is setting up a task force to
investigate oligarchs should look into
people who are russian propagandists and
shilling for putin that's being if you
are a foreign asset
to a dictator it should be investigated
they used to arrest people for doing
stuff like this
every american should be wondering
why our white house and our democratic
party
seem to be mimicking putin's propaganda
style
and seeking out ways to silence free
speech
what exactly are they afraid of hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else